[Music]
you've been caught with your pants on
the ground and you're out of toilet
paper and you can't get any more at
least not how you'd normally go about
getting it but toilet paper isn't the
only thing you need there are five food
groups but all you've got our empty
cupboards this is what if and here's
what would happen if all the grocery
stores closed
there are roughly 40,000 retailers in
the u.s. that would be classified as
grocery stores they range in size and
style and the type of goods they provide
but these are the places where most
people in developed countries get their
food and they often get much more than
they need grocery stores provide
necessities but they're also designed to
make money there's a science to the way
that grocery stores are laid out they
entice customers to purchase items
they'll necessarily need and this
explains why some grocery stores stock
as many as 45 thousand different items
while the average consumer only needs
about 300 items in their home it also
explains why American grocery stores
contribute 10 percent of all food waste
sold what if they simply stopped
operating how would we adapt to life
without the one-stop shop and how long
would it take before the inconvenience
drives us all crazy
for those tech-savvy computer wizards
among you viewers yes we know you can do
all your shopping online
in fact 11 percent of consumers are
already doing this but a world without
grocery retailers would have fewer
grocery wholesalers the food you'd want
would still exist but it wouldn't be as
readily available because massive supply
chains will have been disrupted and even
if you were willing to pay a higher
price for online grocery
some of the items on your list like
fresh produce would be harder to get
maybe you like to start your day with a
healthy dose of potassium or something
sweet like a chocolate croissant well if
you live in the US or Canada for example
you'd have to change your routine
bananas and cacao aren't grown there and
with fewer international exports and
imports the goods we love from abroad
would be harder to obtain from now on
most of the flavors you taste would be
much more domestic but luckily seventy
percent of the world's food is grown on
small farms with about 25 acres of land
so while we wouldn't enjoy the
convenience or the variety we take for
granted today we wouldn't be in a total
crisis in fact we'd probably live
healthier happier lives and we'd save
some money too for the items you
couldn't get online
you'd have to visit specialty stores or
local farms to get your produce meat
fish wheat and dairy while it would be
incredibly time consuming it would make
you a smarter consumer you'd think more
about what you need and wouldn't be as
easily exposed to impulse marketing like
all that candy at the register you could
also just start growing your own fruits
and vegetables neighborhoods could
establish community gardens which have
been proven to reduce crime and would
provide low-income families with access
to healthy food community gardens also
improve local air and soil quality they
increase biodiversity and they've
reduced neighborhood waste through
composting but if we're okay for food
what about toilet paper and other
necessities okay so the toilet paper you
might have to buy online or you could
just take a shower when you're done your
business or you could treat yourself and
buy a bidet who knows it could be fun
as for soap you can make that yourself
too
all you really need is water lye and oil
so while we've proven that we could
survive and probably thrive without
grocery stores making the change would
definitely be a hard adjustment we could
probably build happier and healthier
communities if grocery stores closed but
we'd also have to adapt our tastes there
are pros and cons to grocery stores one
of the benefits is being able to taste
flavors from in faraway places which we
wouldn't be able to access so easily
without grocery stores and again grocery
stores encourage people to buy beyond
their needs and spend beyond their means
and the food that is in soles goes to
waste did you know that up to 50% of the
produce grocery stores throw out is
still edible now while we might not see
a mass closure of grocery stores anytime
soon we can still learn from this what
if by thinking more about our shopping
habits and becoming smarter consumers
grocery stores are a good reminder that
we all have the same needs
so think harder about what you really
need while considering other people's
needs as well but if you think we're big
spenders now can you imagine how much
more we'd consume if humans were five
meters tall well that's a story for
another what if